erstattung nicht jüngere murat kamera
jung der ich finde nicht nur kamera
hallo herr wir sind gerade nicht in
deutschland sondern in den niederlanden
zu beteiligen in dem wunderschönen
freizeitpark mir sind wir gerade in der
pfannkuchen werkstatt an der kirche und
werden hier auch gleich das essen und
was packen
ich mache mich nur darauf hinweisen dass
längst über für den messe in belek den
krieg bereit
und da sind wir freitag samstag und
sonntag für euch da mit meinem gesamten
team meine freunde sind dabei und wir
werden wirklich was richtig cooles zeug
machen
ich bin natürlich david kochen und
backen der liga sind es mir damit
arbeiten mit einem klose schoss murat
ist dabei und natürlich ganz viel musik
ist diesmal dabei ist diesmal auch dabei
haben richtig tolle überraschung für
euch und ich habe natürlich auch unseren
mitarbeitern ganz viele tolle neuheiten
dies auch momentan nur auf der messe
dann vergeben wir hier zu sehen geben
wird so jungs macht man nicht so einen
quatsch hier neben mir
und wir haben zum beispiel auf brutalste
weise hätten dabei und bleibt richtig
toll
wir verlosen tickets mit dem messer ist
nix spielt die küche karotin etwa ein
kampf mit der ella und süß haben wir
gehen mal raus
[Musik]
zum beispiel das macht den tag
und ich bin einfach begeistert haben wir
werden heute morgen gab sich klar sein
mit hans vergessen mit dem messer ja es
gibt 100 karten zu verlosen hatten jetzt
zu verlosen das heißt wenn ihr auf die
messe kommen wollen und schreibt einfach
unter diesen beitrag schreibt es heißt
eine messe welt und er bringt sich ins
da drängt sich jemand rein
[Musik]
so sind auch unter diese e mail das
natürlich atme gewinne e mail besteht
die wirklich bin ihr gewonnen habt gibt
die e mail das haben wir werden euch ist
anzukommen messe dhl ccs welt.de
das muss auf jeden fall vorbei ist in
essen und trinken wir haben auch folke
dies auch kostenlos haben erzählt all zu
bringen
[Musik]
also liebe österreich haben wir freuen
uns riesig drauf und nächste woche
freitags bis sonntags immer in wels auf
der messe schaut vorbei messpunkt welt
genau wie heißt die adresse noch nie
heißt die e mailadresse hast so messi
lcc die welt sallys welt.de er hat sich
so eine blöde e-mail-adresse ausgesucht
als geht 100 karten zu verlosen
ihr bekommt sofort bescheid ihr kommt
specht bis morgen bescheid und bekommt
eine e mail
also wenn ihr bis morgen email bekommen
habt ihr die karten gewonnen
ansonsten gibt es die karten auch vor
ort
ich hab da stecken studenten oder gar
keinen bock auf mitnehmen kann es bei
fragen oder mit geht
[Musik]
doch ist es gut manchmal zauber zauber
mann war die tür auf es ist cool also
macht's gut
[Musik]